you ready to go fishing
[Music]
[Music]
look at this campsite people this is not
the most remote spot in the world
but you can drive your car right up to
it we've got fishing right there
plenty of driftwood for firewood oh
this is gonna be nice
[Music]
okay
is
all right well we've been here 10
minutes he's already got his boots and
clothes wet we'll let those dry and
they'll be ready to get wet again
tomorrow
all right little man there you go now
you can go play in the water to your
heart's content
well for those of you who haven't met
him this is my youngest boy jacob
say hi jake hi and uh we're doing some
cat fishing and carp fishing
and uh we're just gonna see what
happened this is a body of water i've
never fished before i have no idea
what to expect i just found this little
local campground
on the banks of this beautiful lake and
said how
awesome would it be to be able to camp
and fish all night
just hang out here with me and jacob i
just don't see how we're gonna lose here
this is gonna be fun no matter what
happens
what do you say jacob should we get our
fishing rods in the water yeah
all right let's do it
well if this bank fishing don't work out
i brought my boat too so
we're gonna get something why i brought
gear for catfish i brought gear for carp
so i'm gonna chuck three rods out for
carp and three rods out for catfish
and we'll see what happens i might
switch it up based on the results
for carp bait i'm using a classic this
is ponco
mixed with powdered jell-o mix and sweet
corn
this stuff actually works really good
for catfish and for carp
so we can catch a lot of stuff on this i
got
a perfect mine
if you're going to be fishing from the
shore these bite and run reels are
absolutely amazing they have two drags
and they have this little clutch that
chooses between them
so right now the fighting drag is
selected and the drag is tight
you put the resting drag on there and
then it's nice and easy and i can adjust
how tight or loose the resting drag is
stick this in the rod holder and a fish
comes
can't steal my rod and then as soon as i
pick up my rod
turn the handle boom it's ready to fight
the fish
all right these are my bite alarms if
any fish comes along
it's really sensitive and you can adjust
the sensitivity and the tone and the
volume
and i even have a wireless receiver that
allows me to
tell if i'm getting bites inside my tent
without cranking the volume up
for catfish bait i'm going to use use
these minnows
daddy i'm just going to hook them
through the back like that chuck them
out there
and catfish will slurp that up
we're gonna take one of these minnows
that didn't make it we're gonna use him
as bait
gonna hook that up
well we've got six rods out if there's
any catfish or carp in this cove we're
gonna find out about it
well we're gonna be here for two nights
in three days so we got plenty of time
to try to figure out the fishing here
and uh just have a good time me and jake
it's not too often that me and him just
get to hang out
so much free firewood around here
well we got a fire going we're gonna
make some dinner here a little bit
and i can hear a bald eagle going
bonkers over there
well i've been staring at this cove for
about an hour and we've gotten a few
bumps and hits but
i'm only really seeing small stuff a
little bluegill and
white perch jumping but i'm thinking i
might take one of the rods and downgrade
to a very small little hook and put some
earthworms on it
check it out there and try to catch some
of these bluegill and white perch i see
jumping
that's some little number eight hooks
catfish love earthworms carp love
earthworms everything
loves earthworm we'll give that a shot
see what happens
oh did you take nibbles out of my my
apple
thanks buddy
well it's not a white perch but a yellow
perch my guess
is the big boys are waiting till sunset
to come in here and chomp down on some
of those little fish so
this might be some pretty awesome night
fishing in here
all right we got a can of chicken soup
here
okay i'm gonna stick that chicken soup
in some hot water to warm it up
now we're gonna start cooking some
grilled cheese sandwiches
oh no oh no
a little bit toasty
you hear the fish alarm yeah over here
little bluegill all right we're gonna
put this bluegill in here
to keep him alive
oh oh we gotta we got a fish do we got a
fish
yeah there we go oh hey jacob
hey dick look at that
he hit that cut bait
there you go bud
this one you want this one all right
that good yeah it's good
i'm kind of in the top
there we go nice healthy blue catfish
thinks about 10 11 pounds
[Applause]
there he goes
why don't you hop in there you feeling
good bud
yeah good
i got a little bit of a problem i was
planning on making sausage
and egg sandwiches for breakfast
tomorrow over the campfire but
apparently campfires are only allowed
after
4 p.m to midnight so
i can't do that so i'm gonna go ahead
and make my breakfast now
and i can just use my little butane
stove to try to heat them up in the
morning
we'll see how that goes
well it's getting pretty late so i'm
gonna reel up my rods i'm gonna go to
bed
i'll see you guys in the morning
jacob had a little bit of a rough night
last night he woke up crying and so i
put him in the bag with me and
had calmed him down and we're just gonna
let him sleep until he's done and
then we're gonna get some breakfast and
we got a lot of fun things playing today
well i got a little time to kill before
jacob wakes up so i'm gonna tie up some
leaders
and get ready for our catfish on the
boat today
you ready to eat some breakfast in bed
you like it yeah some pants on
get you all covered in sunscreen let's
go out on the boat okay
you guys may notice all this yellow
stuff on the water
that's pollen i've never seen anything
like it until i moved to virginia
the pollen gets so bad in the springtime
you got to scrape it off
your windshield in the morning if you
don't have hay fever you will
[Music]
well the fish are kind of spread out and
the bottom of the water is
really flat so that's a good candidate
for drift fishing we're just going to
put out some gear and just let the
the wind slowly take us across the water
we're covering a lot of ground hopefully
we'll uh we'll find something honey
look at that here
what do you think should we eat them
yeah
well there we go it's my live well
what do you think jacob should we go get
lunch yeah
all right let's take a little lunch
break
there we go let him sit there
[Music]
oh
my i'm tired how are you buddy you tired
here you go bud you want some cup of
noodle yeah
[Music]
[Music]
oh i'm tempted just to sit here and
take a nap but i think jacob wants to go
back out on the boat
and uh that's not gonna last so i think
we better go do that
well i found a spot that's out of the
sun so it feels nice if nothing else
maybe the fish have the same thought
well the breeze is a little bit
stiff and it's causing us to drift
faster than i'd like so
i went and tied my net in the water
to my rod holder to act as a drift sock
and it just acts as a drag in the water
to keep the wind from blowing us too
fast so
that seems to be working really well and
we're
just at the right speed
yeah that is a big fish buddy
i got the net ready don't worry yeah you
almost got it buddy
oh i can see him
have you caught a fish on your fishing
rod yeah you did a great job
he was super feisty
little tiny hook that's perfect eating
size right there
that was a horrible idea there we go
there's our live well you want to go
back to the campsite yeah
all right let's go back to camp we got
some catfish to cook up
[Music]
well jay shall we cook up some
[Music]
well we're catfish eat that smaller
catfish we caught so i'm gonna go get my
bag here
and let go the one we caught previously
and he's off oh yeah
oh yeah he tried to jump out you ready
to eat your catfish
yeah all right let's cook them up
[Music]
um
all right jake since it's your catfish
i'll make your sandwich first
[Music]
catfish po boy sandwich you like yours
jacob
yeah oh
well the wind finally died down and the
sun's setting that means the catfish
might be moving in
i'm pretty tired but i might check a rod
or two out there just see what happens
we got three rods out uh we're gonna
hang out by the fire just see what
happens
what i back got huge
yeah i lay down bud
[Music]
about a 10 pounder
yay aren't you supposed to be in bed
i got jacob down to bed and uh had a few
fish on
just hanging out by the fire taking it
easy it's just a wonderful
wonderful night but i will see you guys
in the morning
good morning bud
breakfast of champions there you go
[Music]
oh this is such a fun trip if you guys
want to try doing more fishing or learn
more about fishing for catfish
check out my other channel the catfish
and carp youtube channel i've been
posting videos there for
seven years now and there's over 500
videos on that channel
including fun adventures with the kids
and lots of tutorials
related to fishing and if you guys want
to learn more about my gear
uh whether it's my tent my cots my rods
whatever i'm gonna put links and
information down in the video
description so you guys can know more
about that as well
check it out i got this little duffel
bag here this side says dirty
this size is clean and there's a little
flexible cloth barrier inside and so you
shove your clothes in
and they're all clean and then as you
use them you put them in the dirty side
you can keep your laundry straight
hey jacob did you have a good time yeah
if you want to see more camping videos
from the outdoor boys youtube channel
don't forget to check out our camping
video playlist with over 40 videos i'll
put a link in the video description
but as always it's time to say goodbye
and i'll see you guys
next saturday thanks for watching
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching